اختلف فتخليا عن مشاعرهما تجاه اطفالهما
وذهب كل منهما في طريقه اب وام مصريان
يقيمان في الكويت تركا اولادهما 6 في
المنزل دون رعايه وبلا ماكل ومشرب
والمفاجاه الصادمه وجود رضيعه بينهم لم
يتجاوز عمرها الاشهر الثلاثه
وفي تفاصيل القصه خلافه اسريه نشبت بين
الزوجين وعلى اثرها اقام الابلد احد
اصدقائه وتركت الام الشقه التي تقيم فيها
مع ابنائها دون ان تترك لهم اي طعام الامر
الذي استلزم ان يتناوب طفلان في الذهاب
الى المدرسه لرعايه شقيقتهما الرضيعه التي
لم يتجاوز عمرها ثلاثه اشهر بحيث تذهب
الطفله الكبرى للمدرسه يوما وتغيب الاخر
وكذلك يفعل شقيقها
وبحسب ما نقل الاعلام المحلي عن مصدر امني
فان ابنه الوافدين اتصلت على عمليات وزاره
الداخليه الكويتيه وقالت ان والديها تركها
واشقائها الخمسه وهم روعه ولا يجدون ما
ياكلونه منذ يومين وعلى الفور تم تقديم
الرعايه للاطفال ونقلهم الى المخفر وتقديم
الوجبات لهم حيث تم اختار الشرطه
المجتمعيه التي تولت امر الرعايه الاطفال
وتم تسجيل قضيه بحق الزوجين بعنوان
الاهمال في رعايه قاصر وتوجيه بعدم تجديد
اقامات الزوجين المصريين واطفالهما سته
ومنحهم اقامه مؤقته تنتهي مع نهايه العام
الدراسي